i have a play for you in three acts
this tells you a lot about the situation
that conservatives find themselves in in
the country
yesterday aoc tweets out about the whole
gamestop thing and the markets and
everything she tweets that quote
this is unacceptable we need to know
more about robin hood's decision to
block retail investors from purchasing
stock while hedge funds are freely able
to trade the stock as they see fit
as a member of the financial services
committee i'd support a hearing if
necessary so i read that and i say wow
i have common ground with aoc okay
works for me ted cruz
our pal you know senator cruz who uh
we'll be talking with on verdict very
shortly probably about this he responds
he says
fully agree aoc responds quote
i'm happy to work with republicans on
this issue where there's common ground
but you almost had me murdered three
weeks ago
so you can sit this one out happy to
work with almost any other gop
that aren't trying to get me killed in
the meantime if you want to help you can
resign
i give senator cruz a lot of credit
for engaging in good faith trying to
reach out to somebody like aoc find some
common ground
they're not interested they're not
interested
clearly i'm glad he tried i'm glad he
tried
shows that we we are trying and they are
not
but now we've learned a lesson there too
first of all i like how aoc says well
i'm willing to work with any republican
but not ted cruz
and not donald trump and not this one
and not that one and no republican she
doesn't think any republican is
legitimate
he almost had me killed uh what what is
your evidence for that oh of course you
don't have any
doesn't matter they
hate us on the left they have been
saying for months now that we are
all nazis and white supremacists
who should be kicked off of twitter
who should be kicked out of our jobs who
should be
kicked out of our schools who should be
kicked off of our investing apps
who should be kicked out of our banks
who should be ostracized utterly
from society and conservatives
we do this thing or we try to win their
respect
we're not going to we try to do this
thing where we try to prove we're not
racist
we're not going to it's not going to
work
aoc is going to do what aoc wants to do
the left is going to do what what the
left wants to do they are not
going to try to work with republicans in
any way
they are going to follow the science
the science of progressivism if you
enjoyed that break from disinformation
historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
you